with millions of Americans
self-quarantine ndu to the coronavirus
many workers are still being called to
people's homes for deliveries and repair
work and things like that people like
Amazon employees electricians and
plumbers are working very long hours to
keep up with the demand and some are now
getting sick Adriana Diaz reports on
these workers who were risking their
health you know where we work yeah
Saro Sharif is an Amazon employee at the
Shikoku fulfillment center in Minnesota
and part of a coalition pushing for
better work conditions according to
workers and media reports at least 10
Amazon warehouse employees across the
country have contracted coronavirus
leaving some employees feeling
vulnerable
she says Amazon did shut down her
facility for a day for cleaning but says
then it was business as usual they have
thousands of employees so from one shift
another shift comes in to deal with the
increased demand during the corona virus
pandemic Amazon senior vice president
Jay Carney told CBS News last week that
the company is hiring even more workers
and adding sick days we are adding an
extra two weeks of paid time off for
anyone who's diagnosed with kovat or has
been quarantined and we're trying to
support all of our associates as best we
can
plumbers are also making house calls
because people are home self isolating
says Jeff Baer in Dallas Texas he says
his family worries about his safety we
do the precautionary things we need to
as I get home electricians find
themselves inside people's homes -
making necessary repairs they also worry
about contracting coronavirus wear latex
gloves we're wearing face masks we are
also wearing shoe covers which that's
part of our service
according to the Seattle Times Amazon
told some drivers to always maintain a
six-foot distance and some warehouse
workers to keep at least three feet
apart we haven't heard back from Amazon
yet about those claims but they did tell
CBS News that they've instituted an
array of changes at both warehouses and
with delivery workers including telling
drivers to disinfect their cars at the
beginning and end of every shift many
consumers are also disinfecting boxes
after a study in the New England Journal
of Medicine found that the virus can
live on cardboard for up to 24 hours
Tony yeah that's worrying Adriana thank
you very much I mean so much to remember
Tony and be wary of you know you know we
keep saying we're all in this together
which is true but some people are more
on the front lines and others and I
think we have to be mindful and applaud
those people a lot of those people have
to make a choice between making a living
continuing to being grateful that they
are but putting themselves in greater
risk they know they are on the other
hand we need their work
Adriana thank you very much